Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Jason
from Virginia. Jason from Virginia,
welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David,
How's it going? It's going well. Hey. Just
following up about that tweet controversy,
how do you feel about getting acknowledged by
Donald Trump Jr and potentially the Taliban? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, here's something
that's fascinating. Donald trump jr and the
Taliban were able to find common ground. They
really didn't like my tweet about gun safety.
Now, Don Junior didn't like it because he
falsely claims and whether he believes it or not,
that I'm blaming the kids who died for the
shooting, which of course, I'm not. I'm blaming
the politicians who send thoughts, prayers and
do nothing else. The Taliban liked I'm sorry,
didn't like what I said, but their context
was that I'm just that I think they use the
term Zionist, which for them just means
Jew. They took the anti-Semitic approach.
So, I mean, listen, politics, I guess, makes
strange bedfellows, Don Jr And the Taliban
uniting against David Pakman It is. It's not
the way I expected the week to go, I admit.
Speaker 2: I couldn't believe it. And then, you
know, reading just all the hateful comments,
just, you know, but it made me realize that
what we see online isn't relevant, you know,
or representative of the real world or.
Speaker 1: In what sense.
Speaker 2: Or what we just like, you know, the
online audience is maybe more amplified and,
you know, oh, yeah, maybe the
general population feels right.
Speaker 1: And you know, what's funny is
in the last few days I've been out usually
like when I go to the grocery store, one or two
people recognize me, or if I'm in a restaurant,
like one person will recognize me or whatever.
It's like they all just come up to me. They have
no idea about the controversy. Like, you know,
it's like every 5 seconds I'm getting a tweet,
but out there, it's sort of like most normal
people are just kind of behaving normally.
Speaker 2: Um, very good, because some
of the comments were threatening in a way
that was concerning to me.
Speaker 1: So of course,
yeah. And there's actually, there's a number
of law enforcement investigations already into
those. You might be shocked to hear.
Speaker 2: Wow. Yeah. All right. Well,
thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right.
There's Jason from Virginia.
Great to hear from you.